the first time i put on this batsuit  there's so much more maneuverability  you could actually jump around you could  crash into stuff  [Applause]  the suit does not make him invincible  it's just a few panels of bulletproof  armor and the rest is how much bruce  believes in it  and how much his adversaries are scared  of it  i like the handmade nature of everything  you can see the construction  it's an element of showing how do it  yourself his version of batman is his  tactical knife is actually  stored as part of his chest plate and is  actually his bat logo  even the batmobile looks like something  he's built himself in his basement  obviously it looks pretty cool  [Music]  i hope you're listening bruce wayne okay  for the sins of your father  what have you done  maybe this is all coming to an end  what is  the batman  who are you under there  isn't over  [Applause]  you